for over a thousand years britain has
had a royal family today we have the
windsors but who exactly are they
[Music]
the lineage of the royal family can
pretty much be traced back to william
the conqueror in 1066.
since then almost every successive king
or queen has had some sort of relation
to him went through blood or marriage
but it wasn't until 1917 the family took
the name windsor before then the royals
were known by their house names so the
tudors and the stewards for example but
during the first world war king george v
wanted to distance himself from his
german relatives so the house of saks
coburg gotha became the house of windsor
by far the most famous windsor is queen
elizabeth ii
she is the longest reigning monarch the
country has ever had she has four
children charles ann andrew and edward
my lord pray be seated
prince charles is next in line for the
throne and his mother's longevity has
made him the longest and oldest serving
heir apparent
in british history
prince william is third in line to the
throne he and his wife catherine are
among the most popular royals with the
public
prince harry and megan are two more
extremely well-known members of the
family but the mexican spat with the
firm saw them step away from royal life
in total the queen has eight
grandchildren and twelve
great-grandchildren
so good it's quite a quite a gathering
[Music]
the royal family is large and while many
of them are recognized around the world
and seen as senior royals the line of
succession is long and contains some
names you may not have heard of
aside from the top tier of royals there
are some famous faces like princess
beatrice and princess eugenie but also
perhaps less well-known ones like prince
michael who is one of over 30 cousins
that the queen has a fun fact about
michael is that when he was born in 1942
he was seventh in line to the throne now
he's been relegated all the way down to
50 seconds somebody else can do the
rest of it
there are also a number of royal family
members who do not have an official
title probably the most well-known royal
in this category is the former olympic
equestrian zara tindall archie and
lillabet harry and megan's children also
don't have titles but that could change
when prince charles becomes king when
they could qualify for hrh status of
course a lot though depends on how much
harry and megan are involved in the
family at that stage lillabet who is the
queen's 11th grandchild and 8th in line
to the throne is also the most senior
royal to have dual us uk citizenship
the members of the royal family who work
full time for the queen are funded by
something called the sovereign grant as
well as her majesty's personal wealth
and her portfolio as sovereign the
government-funded portion the sovereign
grant also covers the maintenance of the
occupied royal palaces and therefore the
homes of the senior royals lucky enough
to live in them
prince charles as the prince of wales is
slightly different he earns money from
the duchy of cornwall a large area of
land mainly in the southwest of england
the prince uses part of this income to
meet the costs of his private life and
those of his wife the duchess of
cornwall as well as his sons prince
william and prince harry however many
royals choose to work normal jobs 10th
in line to the throne princess beatrice
is vice president of a software company
her sister princess eugenie runs an art
gallery and peter phillips who is the
queen's oldest grandson through his
mother anne runs a sports and
entertainment company
and most famously since stepping away
from royal duties prince harry has
started working for a start-up and also
announced that him and megan are going
to appear in a netflix series
the british royal family is sprawling to
say the least but the future and size of
the british monarchy will depend upon
the youngest senior royals and the
decisions that are made after the reign
of queen elizabeth comes to an end
[Music]